this morning a new front door for
america's biggest city
new york's penn station has been around
for more than 100 years the trains at
penn have never stopped running but
what's above them has been built
destroyed neglected and now born again
as of this year january 2021 a stunning
new space is open in midtown manhattan
carrying with it many of the long time
hopes dreams and struggles
that have defined not just a city but a
nation
the saint louis leaving 1255
weskey track number 12. penn station has
always been
both a place and an idea deep in the
americans heart is the urge to be on the
move
there isn't a train he wouldn't take no
matter where it's going
when it was first built at the turn of
the last century it was a monumental
project that involved tunneling under
two rivers
and building an edifice that evoked
ancient rome
conceived by industrial titans and
delivered by workers who sometimes gave
their lives
penn was an enormous moment in american
history
through new york's terminals serving 10
railroads
move more passengers commuters and
visitors each year than the combined
population of all western europe
it also quickly became a star player in
american movies
cut it out and take that thing off
you're going to maine not to mars
goodbye but over the decades
as the nation moved away from trains
toward cars and planes
this architectural masterpiece became a
money pitch
headed toward bankruptcy the
pennsylvania railroad company sold the
air rights to the property
new york's pennsylvania railroad station
has reached the end of the line
and announced their once prized jewel
would be torn down
i think that this is a great building
and part of our heritage and that it
must be preserved
despite objections that plan moved
forward the huge granite monument to the
age of elegance is falling to the
records
new york's grand gateway was replaced by
a massive modern
complex above ground a new madison
square garden
while underground the new penn station
would be relegated into what quite
plainly would become a dark
dirty shell of itself a commentator said
after its destruction
one entered the city like a god one
scuttles in now
like a rat the greatest city in the
world
had the crappiest front door in the
world paul goldberger is a pulitzer
prize-winning architectural critic
losing penn station in 1963 was what
woke
a much broader section of new york up to
the
problem it woke up new york it also woke
up the rest of the country
totally penn's destruction helped shift
the conversation
in the united states there was less
impulse to wipe the slate clean
just to make a point and more emphasis
on saving and reviving what was
i think it's a great moment because it's
the beginning of
putting back pennsylvania station the
idea to restore
penn to its former glory had no bigger
champion
than the man whose name now graces its
facade senator daniel patrick moynihan
america is the land of the
second chance but surely
there has been none such of this
dimension
and this consequence in our time for
decades the idea sputtered
until now
this week nearly six decades after the
old penn building was demolished
new york state governor andrew cuomo
officially introduced the 1.6 billion
dollar
moynihan train hall we build this as a
statement of who we
are and who we aspire to be
we were given a tour by the architects
who designed it we tried to reveal as
much of the history of the building as
possible roger duffy
and colin coop are with the design firm
som which has been working on the
project for more than two decades
i grew up in the midwest and to come to
new york and
realize when you arrive at the city that
it does not have a good front door of
any kind no matter which mode of transit
you use
it's very rewarding to give it something
worthy of the city
the building was built as a utility
building this was a post office sorting
facility not conceived as a train
station and so we
discovered this what used to be the mail
sorting room
the mail sorting room from the historic
farley post office has become the
station
right next to the old one it's a
combination of classic
and cutting edge trusses and columns
from the old post office were preserved
but a vast network of parabolic
skylights was placed
on top of them all of it letting in
maximum sunlight
one of the biggest differences here is i
mean you go into the old penn station
you're subterranean it feels very dark
here completely different story yeah
william flynn is the new president of
amtrak
one of the biggest beneficiaries of the
new building we're celebrating our 50th
anniversary
as amtrak in 2021 we started operations
in 1971
and so for 35 years of our
life so far we've been thinking about
this station
you started running amtrak just as the
lockdowns began
in march that is a heck of a time to
start when this
monumental project is still being
finished hopefully being finished
on time and on budget yeah it looks like
it
and it was as of new year's day at 6 02
a.m when the first train rolled out the
nation's newest train hall
is fully in operation trains are always
such a hot topic people have very
passionate feelings
one way or the other why do you think
people should be traveling on trains
more well there are a number of reasons
but but let's just start with the
environmental impact a passenger seat
mile
on amtrak is 87 percent less impact in
the environment than traveling by car
74 less impact in the environment than
traveling by
by plane it's convenient and it's a
great ride
there's almost too much to take in here
at first sight but the giant clock that
hangs in the middle of the hall
below that web of skylights is already a
hit
there's avant-garde artwork including a
stunning display of skyscrapers hanging
upside down schedule boards that are
actually easy to read
and waiting rooms that actually make you
want to wait
all of it a nice reminder that just
because we used to build great things
doesn't mean we still can't with covid
there's not going to be a huge amount of
traveling
for a while more yet but in fact this is
the time when you invest for the future
it's in tough times that you build to
bring you to a better future
that's what they did and that's what
they did wow
got a lot of questions so the post
office that was there is still there
and it's still in operation they're just
not using that big old mail
sorting room that's what the train
station is there's also commercial space
now
the first and biggest tenant is facebook
wow
yeah in that in that new station area
and one of the concerns
for amtrak is that you know not
everybody has access to trains
like we do here in the northeast and so
i think what one of their plans for 2021
and beyond is to really expand they're
talking about routes
chicago to milwaukee to minneapolis
raleigh to charlotte
atlanta to birmingham to new orleans las
vegas to los angeles so
great way to travel we'll see great
station